[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he leaves us no recourse
[Music]
are these the wages of loyalty raised
earth and burnt corpses
you and no other must decide how we
proceed
[Music]
you are a leader and must be the beacon
others look to when the night is darkest
together with these fields today you
burn i promise to do
all in my power to see us through this
safely every last one of us
far far away lies the continent of
nausilia
comprised of three nations and limited
deposits of salt
and iron the constant feuds among the
nations over these precious resources
eventually ignited into a great conflict
known as the salt iron war though the
hostilities ceased with an uneasy truce
decades later the flames of war
threatened to engulf the realm
once again you are all that remains
caught in a tangled fiery web of plots
and conspiracies
a brave group from glenbrook fights to
save their kingdom from the powers that
would orchestrate their downfall
our benefit you say
in this new tactical rpg battles take
place on terrain with different
elevations
a character's attack range is determined
by their location and their equipped
weapon
the range can be extended by attacking
from higher ground with long range
weapons
such as bows and arrows thus your forces
can use the terrain and other elements
to gain the upper hand an enemy
outflanked is susceptible not
only to your initial attack but also a
powerful blow from the ally positioned
behind the enemy
what have we here
charge into an enemy to send them flying
into position for a follow-up attack
we wish link attacks together by first
casting ice magic on the flames to
create water terrain
then electrify the area with lightning
magic
it is of the utmost importance to survey
the battlefield
before taking action
[Music]
throughout the story you will be faced
with making
important decisions in a variety of
situations
[Music]
utility morality liberty
collectively your decisions will
establish your conviction
affecting how the story unfolds and who
will join your cause
once more i would ask you plainly do we
or don't we
relinquish prince roland to esdrost
critical decisions that may determine
the fates of
nations are settled by vote on the
scales of conviction
use information you've gathered to sway
allies toward your favored cars
the story will significantly change
based on how the votes are cast
so they refuse to relinquish him to us
lies
his hand was forced as more and more
critical decisions are made
your journey may take you down paths
divergent
from those of other players you will see
what true
might is
project triangle strategy a brand new
tactical rpg from square enix
will launch in 2022 please be on the
lookout for more information
in the future after this presentation
a demo version of this game will be
available to download on nintendo eshop
and in the future we'll conduct a survey
to gather player feedback
we look forward to hearing your
responses on the demo